hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're back out monster on a
world and we're gonna be doing one of
the solo guides are gonna be talking
about tea Ostra just rose one of the
three elder dragons you have to find
tracks for in the ancient rise quest
once again if you need help with that
check one of my more recent videos I
have a guide on how to get those super
quick if you're having a little bit of
trouble I know I was that's why I put
out the guide in terms of this video
though he's gonna be one of the last
he's going to be the last three in our
guide video for the ancient dragon quest
so let's get right into it
according to the Sociology report teo
Stroh's had wings and tail are his weak
points they're also the three points
that are breakable and severable the
best place to hit him is right in the
face regardless of your weapon because
that's where you're going to do the most
damage the other point the other areas
also do damage as well but they're not
as good as the forehead on the right
hand side it shows his weaknesses are
water and ice if you're using an element
and poison or stun for ailments as for
gear I recommend some fire resistance
gear as some as some good defense I was
using need gnorga ghonte set in this
clip but I previously fought him with
hiring Anjanette gear just fine for
equipment mega potions let like always
vitality mantle to negate some hits and
some and some cool drinks the quest will
have some free when you spawn and look
in the box but it doesn't hurt to bring
a few extra cool drinks will protect you
from the fire damage you will receive
when fighting tea Ostra but only when
you're walking in an area with flames or
lava it doesn't protect you from misfire
attacks so just definitely keep that in
mind now that is taken care of let's
move on to his moveset and the area's
you fight him in first off I want to
mention that tea Ostra has what I'm
going to call normal blast and fire
types of phases basically as a summary
is that toasters body will be normal
covered in flames or have sparks on him
but we'll get to that later I just
wanted to explain that really quickly
before I decided to explain it fully
later we're moving on with the move set
the first move that I noticed is is fire
attacks spread he will basically breathe
fire straight ahead and then going from
left to right and then going back from
right to left if you're not within range
you can go and attack his head by
nestling into his arm and head area or
attack his tail either way works this is
a very high damaging attack for you but
if you managed to evade it it is very
very punishable he also has a short fire
attack where he does a quick spray this
doesn't do much name
but it will catch you on fire you could
simply extinguish the flames by rolling
three times and as well if you're also
affected by blasts do the same exact
procedure by rolling three times
he'll also do these two different
jumping attacks one where he pounces to
you and one where he jumps on to you you
don't take much damage but you could
still take damage from this as it is a
type of knock back attack and seems to
do this a lot of times so the damage
will add up so definitely watch out for
his feet the next move in this is this
area of effective blast attack he will
shoot out these particles around him and
on command will blow them all up
simultaneously causing you to take flame
damage simply stay out of the range or
rush him to prevent being hit super
simple
Costa also has a few moves in the air
one being this dive-bomb mover he flies
all the way back and flies right toward
you dive bombing you dodging or sprint
drumming if you're near a wall or out of
a room will work to evade that damage
another is this super huge nuclear bomb
attack where he does this insane damage
run away immediately cuz this will
definitely one-shot you he will fly up
into the air and charge her up a bomb
once that blows up rush in because he
does take his time coming down for the
landing and then you can also land a few
hits while he does that Tiare also has a
tail sweep when you're behind him his
tail will go from right to left and then
left to right again just like in the
clip every single time I still haven't
gotten the timing down for this but I'm
assuming there is a brief window to rush
in after the first tail swoop to give
her underneath him and underneath into
his underbelly regarding his three forms
though normal blast and fire if he's on
fire and you get too close you will
catch on fire and the same for the blast
as well like I said roll three times to
get rid of that super quickly now that
we're done with the moves let's move on
to the areas so the first area I fought
him in is this lava room right near
where you fight that lava fish monster I
don't exactly know how to pronounce his
name but right near that area there are
going to be two neuro toads in the
middle rock platform as well as some
small areas to do some sliding attacks
as well highly recommend you keep him
away from the middle unless you want to
use the nearer toads and fly him on the
side so you have more room to fight the
second area is this really open area
where you also fight some of the other
monsters in this game there is this huge
slope for sliding attacks and a small
ledge for mounting as well as the very
very big ledge at the very top if you
want to go mounting for that I don't
recommend that but it's completely up to
you this area is nice because if it's
very
wide open space commute tons of room to
fight him or run away especially with
that nuclear bomb attack the third area
was this other lava room in which is
where you need to pass through when you
go to his nest but this room and the
first one are where cool drinks like to
come in handy this will allow you to
fight on the lava in this room instead
of just on the rocky stone part where
you have very little room sometimes his
attacks will actually break the stone
parts and cause lava to seep through
which is why cool drinks are very
necessary like I said to give you more
space in the fight instead of that very
tiny stone area nothing really important
in this room though sadly but there is
that and then lastly to end is his nest
this place is another lava room again so
definitely drink your cool drinks if you
have any to reapply that buff if you ran
out and there is a small ledge on the
outside for mounting and also in the
middle of the map it will start to crack
and shoot lava outside of it so
definitely be careful with that because
that will cause some decent damage to
you and also apply the flame damage and
that's it hopefully this guide helped
you guys and if it did please sure to
give it a like subscribe if you're new I
cover Monster Hunter solo guides I still
got a couple more left as well some high
rank quests up at the top I do have the
other previous Elder Dragons as well and
also a couple other monsters if you guys
need those but I've been posting so low
guys I'm going to be doing other
tutorials it seems like a lot of the
other youtubers have done it but I might
as well throw my two cents in for this
as well if you have any other ideas for
videos you want me to do I'll be glad to
look at those and I'll keep that in my
suggestion box my two most recent
Monster Hunter videos are gonna be on
screen if you guys didn't miss those and
want to check those out and with that
guys hope you have a great rest of your
day thanks for watching the video and
peace out